messieurs riche et 1000 r ça fait 20 ans
que vous vous baladez nous vous avons
suivi dans votre balai de la vhs juste
avant l'arrivée du dvd dans votre
boutique be pop juste avant l'arrivée du
gsm dites moi n'est pas une nouvelle
idée pour être bien sûr de pas côté de
la plaque encore devra
là on a inventé la machine à remonter le
temps
les années 80 les années 80 les vrais
chanteurs des années 80 voilà on les a
contactés un par un au point de nous la
joue star des années 80 avec emile et
images pittoresques le début de soirée
jean pierre mader sabrina lio cookie
dingler jean luc lahaye jeanne mas
gilbert montagné et de terrats était
ainsi qu'à c'est super je suis vraiment
peur que même pas mon nom reciva regarde
l cetera
si on nous avait dit qu'on filière au
zénith à temps mais le génie c'est pas
la fin de l'histoire en espagne
à quoi tu penses stade de france
ça vaut
je ne m'inquiète pas à temps se passe
super bien
aka mr nobody
sabrina qu'est ce qui a motivé votre
retour là
d'immostar choix singulier ou au pluriel
les caprices de stars terminée de toute
façon c'est pas vous les stars c'est vos
chansons voilà personne connaît leur
prénom c'est quoi vos prénoms en tic et
tac du but et soirée n'importe qui peut
chanter vos chansons
puis l'on va faire un carton en face on
va faire un carton
du compte pas mettre ça ce soir c'est
laurent voulzy café rue victoria on l'a
dit on prend les tubes de l'époque par
les costumes tomber
v
je fais
jeanne tu vas voir 90 personnes ça
envoie du bois je te remercie ce n'est
pas du tout l'impression
je sais quoi je ferme ma gueule ça c'est
bien jean-luc fait dans la place
je vous adore tu fan de tout ce que vous
faites monsieur rien autographes mais
bien sûr et c'est quoi ta préféré est
relève toi et danse avec la vie s'y
faire c'est julie pietri bah oui